I'm a card-carrying member of the market system
and I'm here to tell you it was the market system that failed.
It was not the government.
A huge percentage of them of the bad loans came out of companies that when fact were regulated.
And were encouraged to do subprime lending.
Where were the regulator's during this period?
They were gone, they were gone, they were nowhere to be found.
The Federal Reserve helped create the housing bubble
by flooding the financial system with money
and by setting the short-term interest rate well below the market's natural rate.
It's not government's heavy hand and overbearing relationship to the markets that caused the crisis,
it's the lack of oversight on the markets that caused the crisis.
it wasn't a light hand of government, it was the hand of government pounding on your head,
trying to make you make subprime mortgages.
Welcome
To this
sixth debate of the third season of the so forum at the sub-culture theater in
Downtown Manhattan, I'm Jean Epstein
director of the Sola forum
We're a special monthly debate series that features topics of special interest to libertarians and aims to enhance
social and professional ties within New York City's
libertarian community we're partnered with Reason magazine and presenting these debates and you can catch audio and video of
all our events on
Reason TV this is an Oxford style debate in which the audience initially votes for against or
Undecided on the resolution and then again after the debate is over
Whoever moves the vote in his or her favor is declared the winner
Go into Soho vote calm to cast your initial vote. You'll find the tonight's
Resolution reads the financial crisis of 2008 was caused mainly by
government induced distortion of markets rather than caused mainly by intrinsic
Market failure here to defend the resolution John Allison John. Please come to the stage
I
Speaking for the negative on the resolution mark sandy mark, please come to the stage
Now we're going to start the PowerPoint presentation for the first time bear with us, we think it'll go well
John Allison, you have 15 minutes to defend the resolution. Please take the podium John
Good evening
I was a longest-serving CEO of a major financial institution when the recent Great Recession occurred my company BB&T
Went through the crisis without a single quarterly loss
I was also leading BB&T lending business in the early
1980s and CEO and there only 90s when the economy experienced other major Corrections
I have a unique insider's perspective on the
recent financial crisis
I served on the committee the Financial Services Roundtable for nine years trying to do something about Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
Which are quite appropriately called government-sponsored enterprises
It was a mathematical certainty
And that Fannie and Freddie were going broke from their enormous purchases of high-risk mortgages
We met with congressmen on numerous occasions including congressman, Barney Frank
I called Barney the evil one because he actually is smart unlike most of the others but
Possibly because Fannie and Freddie were major financial contributors the Democratic Party
And because Barney had a religious conviction that all Americans should be homeowners
He was willing to cheerfully behead anyone that might stand in the way
That's Mike began by drawing a distinction between two related but fairly separate questions about the busting
Housing bubble of 2008 first what causes?
Second once it did occur
Why did it trigger the worst recession since the Great Depression of the 1930s on the second question?
While the toxic mortgages that choked the financial system were bound to bring an economic recession
I believe that the government's reaction the crisis both prolong the downturn and increases severity but in this debate
I'm here to focus only on the first question
What caused it in the first place to defend the resolution the financial crisis of 2008 was called?
Mainly by government induced distortion of markets rather than caused mainly by intrinsic market failure
Let's start with a government entity that has the greatest power to distort markets
The Federal Reserve the Federal Reserve helped create the housing bubble by flooding the financial system with money and by setting the short-term
Interest rate well below the marxist natural rate the best estimate that I've seen of a difference between the interest rate the Fed
Artificially imposed and the markets natural rate comes from a peer-reviewed paper
co-authored by monetary colonists George Celgene
This chart tracks the main findings
It's the difference between the actual interest rate dictated by the Fed and what economists?
estimate to be the natural market rate based on changes in price inflation and in
Productivity the horizontal line on the chart traces the neutral zone with the market interest rate in the fates right feds rate
Converged monetary policy becomes loose when the fluctuating line cuts below the neutral line
and you can see
It starting in year
Monetary policy soon became even looser than it was in the seventies and it's no coincidence
That starting the year 2000 the bubble that had already been forming in the price of phones really begin to take off
the next chart
Hopefully
comes from Nobel prize-winning economist Robert Shiller
and it's based on an index number that adjusts the average houses price for improvements in quality from
overall price inflation it shows many bubbles formed in the 70s and 80s and also it shows that from
1996 to
2000 a very similar many meebo mini bubble had began to form but it's instead of receding as it had in the past the price
started to jump to new highs by
2001 and 2002 quoting Shiller the number-one boom occurred from February
1997 to October
1996 when house prices a real house prices increased 70 percent from
1997 to December
2003 real house prices increased
45%
while I was the looseness in Fed policy having a specialty impact on housing prices whose
monetary policy has been referred to as the punchbowl but gets
Markets drunk in this case the government offered a second punch bowl of the housing
segment starting them in 1980s in Occident
It orchestrated a massive effort to boost homeownership mainly implemented by the giant government-sponsored enterprises
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac in a recent article Mark. Zandi has actually summarized this story pretty well
He wrote that it was the effect of the GSEs Fannie and Freddie to quote expand lending to historically underserved families that caused the crisis
Marx continues the government requirement that Fannie and Freddie help expand lending to these families calls them to
Inappropriately lower their lending standards in the lead-up to the crisis
Which drove other private mortgage lenders to do same and created the downward spiral of unsustainable debt that led to the housing collapse?
I should add however the mark calls this story mythology and even pronation
I regardless story is quite true the government's actions
Happen in plain sight when President Clinton announced his national home ownership strategy in June
1995 he spoke of the need to make it easy for people to own their own homes in 1996 of the partisan
I'm housing and urban development
Begin setting annual goals for the proportion of mortgages of low and income families that Fanny and Fanny were required to buy
The goal was increased each year rising from 40 percent in
1996 to 50 percent by 2001 in a press release dated July 1999
President Clinton announced that the homeownership rate is at an all-time high with more than 66 percent of all American families owning their homes
And reported that goals of Fetty and families purchase and mortgage were being raised quote
Over and above the one point nine trillion dollars in mortgages for twenty 1.1 million families
That would have been generated. The current goals have been retained. The policies continued under Clinton successor George W Bush a
2004 press least from Fannie Mae
Bolted to having provided over three trillion dollars in funds for over 28 million
Underserved families over the course of previous decades. These policies were having affect the climate homeownership rate
Shown in this chart
Reflects that a man pressure was trailing house prices even higher as this chart shows the home rate ownership rate had actually climbed
to a record high of 66 percent by the second quarter of
1998 even earlier than Fred and Clinton had thought by fourth-quarter
2003 in a jump to sixty eight point six percent peaking at 69 percent in second quarter
2004 before it began to fall from
1997 through
2003 Freddie and Fannie alone purchase
1.7 trillion dollars worth of high-risk mortgages that doesn't include active
Participation high-risk mortgages by government agencies that include the Federal Housing Administration and the abettor Veterans Administration
It also doesn't include the rigorous enforcement of the Community Reinvestment Act and other community lending deals
Which require that private lending institution give mortgages to lower-income families
I emphasize that all this happened in the period leading up to 2003 for a special reason a few years ago
I had the privilege of sitting next to mark on a panel about the financial crisis and hearing his main arguments. He repeats the same
Arguments in the article. I just recorded for him
published in September mark tries to refute the idea that government policy was crit crucial and creating the housing bill by citing data from
2004 through
2006 but by focusing on 2004 to 2006
Marcus placed himself in the position of a guy who walks into the theater in the last reel of the movie this chart
Released by Federal Housing
regulators reveals what happened before mark arrived to the scene in a tributes to each major set of institutions from 1990 through
2007 the mortgages that were actually used to purchase homes in its year and it actually under states this year attributable to Freddie and Fannie
Notice the chart has a breakout for private-label securities
These are bonds that are backed by
who of mortgages holders of these bonds receive their payments out of the payments made on the mortgages Fannie and Freddie routinely bought
massive amounts of Hope mortgages and
Packaged them in this form and the private sector did the same and and in fact fede and Fannie bought hundreds of billions of dollars
worth of these private-label securities
To help meet their affordable housing goals imposed by the Department of Housing and Development
But since the chart doesn't reflect these acquisitions the percentage share on this chart over States this year of purchase
Mortgages held by the private sector and under states this year held by Freddie and Fannie
but the chart still shows that in the crucial years from
1997 to 2003 the combined share of the Fannie and Freddie plus out of the
FHA and Veterans Administration was always greater than 60% of all mortgages this with this commanding share
They drove the market in in dollar terms the value of these purchases mortgages more than double for four and forty billion in
1997 to
886 billion in 2003 before leveling off the Rainer went to the private section combined share banks and other lenders this
institution plus the issues of private-label securities
from 1997 to 19
2003 the private sector share with almost always was was always less than 40 percent it shear started to rise into fairly
2004 but barely exceeded 50 prints sent in the single year 2005 and it's mentioned even these figures are
Overstated because so many private-label securities were bought by Freddie and Fannie
Mark should read the January
2019 working paper called Margus mortgage rich since nineteen tiny from which I took these figures
Analysts with a federal agency that issued this report say quite clearly we show that mortgage risks that are already
risen in the
1990s planting the seeds of the financial crisis will before the actual event
Why did the private sector get more heavily involved in late?
2003 the price bubble government policies they created lute lured this in
this chart
On 12-month half price insulin increases mainly in
California reals a key factor notice by June
2000 when the bubble had already taken off prices begin to rise ten percent a year and and by December
2003 by sixteen point four percent now you say give them
now you gave a mortgage to a high-risk debtor with a down payment of just three percent if
The debtor can't meet the payments
You can
always help him reef in the henson thumb will be more for at least ten percent a year or you can foreclose and sell the
house for more than you
Know now, I had two other factors that were fueling the mania. It's mentioned Fanny and Fanny
We're buying up whole mortgages and private mortgage-backed securities by the hundreds of billions of dollars
So the private financial institution Pleet believed they could always sell their toxic mortgage
Sisters these deep-pocket government-sponsored enterprises. They had to back in the federal government on the top of that
There was a delusion that Alan Greenspan head of the Fed would remaining who remained in office through January
2006 would come to the rescue if anything went wrong the bank
He loved to hate the guy in the starched collar at the branch bank on Main Street
he would turn you down for a mortgage because your income wasn't high enough got elbowed aside by banksters like
Angelo Mozilo of the mortgage issuer country
Right who would give anybody a mortgage because the government was there to assume the risk?
Many of these bankers did indeed get bailed out by the government as did Freddie and Fannie
I
Remained the banker you loved to hate and I knew at the time that Fannie and Freddie
Were going bust and the Greenspan had created a financial house of cards
I've heard mark claimed the private sector lost BAM more mortgages were much higher than losses incurred by the government
I've seen a moody study published that tries to butter is this claim in fact a possible?
Look at the data shows the opposite that a government accounting from even greater losses
But it's true that private sector losses were quite substantial when you consider. It's much smaller commitment
One reason is that Freddie and Fannie had the power as pay setting institutions backed by the government to cherry-pick the best the worst
mortgages the best of the worst mortgages of leaving the private sector with the more risky mortgages
The private sector also entered the market much later at much higher prices with mortgages whose average dollar value was higher
So when the crash in prices came the lower down payment mortgages say hell were underwater much sooner and therefore lost much more
I've heard mark make the point that other countries experience house price bubbles. That's true
Since they too have central banks central banks that have to follow the lead of the Fed because the US has the world's reserve currency
But the key difference
Was that when the bus came the US had a much larger proportion of toxic mortgages than any other country
I've heard their excuse mark repeated
Repeat the excuse given by a Greenspan and successor of Ben Bernanke
The housing market was distorted by savings, but but a brought from abroad but much of what they call a savings glut was monetary expansion
Globally by central banks that was only possible because the Federal Reserve's action the so called Savings Club distorted our housing market
Mainly because the huge distortion imposed by Freddie and Fannie and the Fed itself
It's hard to underneath it's hard to overestimate the negative impact on
Lending by private lenders through the regulatory attack on banks forcing banks to do lending that they weren't designed to do
And and that really got the ball rolling
That led eventually to the financial crisis. Thank you very much
Well, you still kept your full 15 minutes mark even though John finished early
Well, thank you Jean thank you so hope for him for the opportunity to be here a
Great place great venue very intimate. She and I go way back I think
Must be 25 or 30 years. So thank you for the invitation and it's great to be on the stage with
John Ellison
a great guy
Fantastic bank. BB&T is
Certainly, one of the best. We I've worked with being BB&T over the years and still do and
It's testimonial to your your leadership. So you've done a fantastic job. I just want to say that I'm not just an egghead economist
I am the chief economist of Moody's Analytics
but I
think it's apropos given the
Subject matter just to give you a little bit of of context about me
I started my own company an economic consulting firm with my brother and my best friend and
We sold it to the Moody's corporation
Now almost 15 years ago. It's hard to believe when when we sold it
We were a good size small company about a little over a hundred employees with offices in different parts of the world
So I've been a part of a start-up. I've been part of a
Small business and now I'm part of a large multinational corporation. I'm also on the board of directors of
mortgage MGIC a mortgage and sure one of the largest in the country and I'm the lead director of
Reinvestment fund which is a CDFI if you don't know what that is. It's a non profit
Investment community development financial institution
We invest in underserved communities all across the country including in this region of the country
So the point is I am a card-carrying member of the private markets. I know it
Well, I do think one more important point. I am part of the Moody's Corp, but I'm not part of the rating agency
so I'm totally separate from the rating agency and
In a separate independent organization, okay
Let me begin by saying that
There are many causes for the financial crisis plenty of blame to go around
Except me it's not my fault. I had nothing to do with it, although
president Trump
Did try to pin it on me back in the 2016 campaign a press release
he didn't like what I was saying about his proposed economic policies and
Apparently I was the one who started the crisis, but I had nothing to do
I was okay with that when it turned out that he also went after warren buffett in the same press release
I'm okay to be in the same press release with Warren Buffett, you know anything he's doing I'm
Good with so wait. I had nothing to do with it
I
think the
principal reason for the crisis however was a colossal
collapse in
the private markets in the financial system
and more specifically in the
complete failure in the mortgage securitization process the private mortgage securitization process the
Private-label securities that john had in one of his charts
Pretty straightforward in the securitization process lenders originated mortgage lenders originate loans
those loans are then sold to
investment banks trusts
investment banks package those loans
And take the principal interest
generated by those loans to back security some mortgage securities that they the investment banks then sell to
global investors across the club, of course the rating agencies rate those
securities and the global investors use those ratings as
An input into their decision around whether to invest in those securities, that's the mortgage securitization process
It's still functioning today
It's a shadow of what it was but you know back in the day prior to the crisis
It was you was rip-roarin and the mortgage securitization process. And again, I'm speaking to you as a person in the middle of the process
watching it was
broken the machine was
completely
Out of sync from the beginning to the end
lenders unscrupulous lenders
originated loans that they knew
Would be unaffordable that ultimately borrowers who took on those mortgages would not be able to pay them
In many cases, they weren't the BB and T's of the world not the regulated banking system
They they weren't the real problem
It was the non banks and the so-called shadow system the country wives of the world the Angelo Mozilo zuv the world
the new centuries of the world
That's where we got ninja loans no income no job no asset
Of course borrowers weren't completely innocent in all this we had many
home buyers that were investors in fact at the peak of
the investment flipping in the housing market back in 2005 2006
nearly 20% of all homes that were sold were to investors and of course these investors pass themselves off as
Homeowners because if they were homeowners, they'd get better terms on the mortgage loan a lower interest rate
And they didn't have to put as much down into the mortgage so they lied about it
And so there was plenty of fraud going on in the mortgage market at this time
So in fact, I remember one just very incredible statistic in Ocean City, New Jersey
That's a that's actually a metropolitan area. There's a lower for near metropolitan errs across the country Ocean City in New Jersey in
2005 and this is HMDA data Home Mortgage Disclosure. Act data seventy percent of all the loans
Originated in that year were to investors to investors. So
lenders were deeply involved if the investment banks
they were making a they were minting money and
In buying those loans securitizing them and selling them off and the entire business model was revolved around volume. We need they need to generate
high levels of activity high levels of
And so they took anyone they got they securitized it sold off to global investors and they went on to the next deal
Rating agencies were involved believe it or not back in the day prior to the crisis
the rating agencies policy was and this was a stated policy that was
Written for everyone to see it was public information
That the rating agency would not
underwrite the loans themselves
they took the information that the investment bank gave them about the mortgage loans and
Used that in their decision around what rating to provide on the Securities?
obviously that was an egregious error in the sense that
You know these loans it was quite obvious many of them were far progeny poorly underwritten
but no wonder writing was doing but again that was
Kind of the way the rating agency
That was the way the rating agency rating agencies operated with regard to other debt
And they just applied that same business model to them to the mortgage loans
and then there's the global investors the global investors they were
Inundated with capital we did have a global savings collide
Largely most fundamentally because it was a period after which China had entered into the World Trade Organization
And came on the global scene very rapidly. They started to run a very large current
Trade surplus and a current account surplus they were getting a lot of dollars in trade
I mean they came into the WTO in 2001 by the mid-2000s
They were rolling in cash and that money those were dollars that had to come back into the United States
They went to investment managers investment managers were flooded with the cash. They didn't know what to do with it
They did stop doing due diligence. They solely relied on the ratings and they plunked down good capital on these bad loans
And it goes beyond that. I mean exacerbating all of this were different features of the system that
ultimately failed
there were
investment vehicles out there that
So-called structured investment vehicles sibs. You may remember the Citibank sieve that blew up in
2007 2008 that
borrowed money short-term money at a low interest rate that money and use that to finance purchases of
subprime mortgage securities and other debt mortgage
Mortgage bonds and of course when you borrow short and you're funding a purchase of an asset
That's the long duration. You set yourself up for a problem
If short-term interest rates rise and funding gets cut off, which is exactly what happened the derivative market took off unregulated
That was key to allowing investors and speculators to double down triple down on their bets in the mortgage market. And of course most
Fundamentally the entire financial system including the banking system. Maybe not be a B and T
But most banks including Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
Which is their the reason for their failure was that they were undercapitalized
they hold very little capital cushion cash in the cash in a sense in the bank that was sitting there in case
to pay for losses that they would ultimately suffer and they didn't have enough capital to withstand the losses that came so the system
Really
Was totally broken
During this period and you can you can see this?
In my first I have a couple of three slides
Forward
Yeah, this is this shows you how
significant the
Growth was you know?
There's an old a banking adage it goes maybe John knows us the bank energy goes if it's growing like a weed
It's probably a weed
and that describes the private mortgage market and you can see that here this shows the share of
mortgage debt outstanding residential mortgage debt outstanding
That's accounted for by the private-label securities market. This is the securitization market that I've been talking about the private market and
Contrasting that with a share of mortgage debt that's accounted for by Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and this accounts for every
Mortgage asset whether it's a loan or security on the balance sheet. You can see that the
private-label securities market took off
There's the weed
between mid 2003 and mid
And share mortgage debt outstanding rose by over 10 percentage points, by the way, this is not origination. This is mortgage debt outstanding
For those who follow this carefully so that gives you a sense of in terms of regeneration
Volume the share going to the private-label securities market was sustainably more than this and you can see at the same time
No surprise the share of mortgage debt accounted for can't afford by Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac fell by 10 percentage points
So it's the private-label securities market they came on very rapidly grew very quickly
the weed and it overtook the
The agencies Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac. And you know it clearly led to the egregious
problems that we had during this period and of course the losses reflect that
This shows who suffered the most who suffered the losses during the financial crisis the lending that was done through the financial crisis
this is just adding up in dollar terms the defaults the blue bar represents the
losses on mortgage loans originated in the bubble in
2003 through 2006 early 2007 by the private market and the Green Line represents
the losses on
Backed by the government including Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
I mean obviously they weren't part of the government prior crisis
But they were implicitly backed and I included them and it also includes FHA VA
Through the entire crisis total losses on all mortgage loans was just over a trillion dollars
so if you look at all the losses and all the mortgage loans originated during this bubble period
It was about a trillion dollars for context. There's ten trillion dollars of mortgage debt outstanding
So the lost rate on mortgage debt outstanding was ten percent ten percent of the value of all mortgage debt defaulted
If you add up the blue bars over time that comes up to five hundred and fifty billion dollars
So that's over half of all the losses that were incurred during as a result of crisis
on those loans originated during that period we're in the private market over half the accounted for 10 20 percent of the market they account
For over half the losses. And of course the product the government sector much smaller share than
their debt outstanding
No, let me in this way
I'm not saying and I'm not arguing the government didn't play a role in all of us it did
But it's not what John thinks it is. It's not the head. It's not
Government's heavy hand and overbearing
Relationship to the markets that caused the crisis it's the lack of oversight on the markets that caused the crisis
Where were the regulator's during this period they were gone they were gone
they were nowhere to be found the first guidance that
regulators the Federal Reserve the
OCC the FDIC issued with regard to subprime lending was in July of
2006 the bubble was already bursting by that point in time
They there was no derivative
There was no regulation of the derivatives AIG lorded up on three trillion dollars of notional value of derivatives
There was no regulation or oversight of the structured investment vehicles
In fact when the city's sieve blew up it was it was a surprise to everyone including the regulators
The lenders that blew up the the guys who took out the system they weren't the regulated banks
They were the non regulated banks
It was a countrywide of the world that took out Bank of America
Was the new centuries of the world that took out the financial system, so it's not the government's heavy hand
It's in fact just the opposite the government was nowhere to be found and it was the government that at the end of the day
Saved the day and you can see that here this shows a measure of stress in the financial system
It's the so-called Ted spread. It's the difference between the rate on LIBOR. That's the interest rate that banks
charge each other for buying and lending to each other relative to the
Treasury yield which is a risk-free rate. So the
If that's if that difference increases that stress in the marketplace, the bankers are saying to the to the other bankers
I don't believe that you're going to be able to pay me back
So you've got to pay me a higher interest rate and you can see that
the the earthquake started back in
2007 with Bear Stearns
it became
Earth-shattering, you know in 2008 on the other side of Lehman Brothers in Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
And it was only with government intervention, ultimately the tarp, which was the bailout fund and interestingly enough
Factoid the day this spread peak and in my mind the day
the financial crisis began to come to an end was the day that the FDIC
guaranteed bank that saying it's money good if you invest in Bank dead and
That marked the end of the crisis in distress
so I'm a card-carrying member of the
Market system and I'm here to tell you it was the market system that failed. It was not the government. Thank you
So so on
rebuttal from John
Allison and can we
You got a phone call?
Yeah, okay. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, maybe yeah, Jane Menten can help you there timekeepers. Yeah Oh God
Okay, start the chiming sorry for that boys
Closely tracked articles and court talks. He's already published. He's simply decided to advance to the housing bubble. Only began in late 2003
any
Academic would say no it started a long time when the private sector is hard to become more involved in the mortgage market
But I walk into the movie the final really misses all the decisive events that occurred until late 2003 in the January
2019 working paper called mortgage risk since 1990 analysts with the Fed raised you see this is report
Say we show the mortgage risks had already risen in the nineties planning and see for the mantle crisis
Since Mark's own data revealed the government dominated the mortgage market the 90s and early
2000s just final statement to be sufficient evidence the real story began before the 2004 period to here are two other
snapshots of
The time of the housing bubble this one traces house prices to rents which hit a new high in December
and in a paper published
title house prices
bubbles in March of 2003 an economist with the Federal Reserve in
San Francisco reported with concern that the ratio between house prices and rents resembling a price bubble
Remember its prices that are bubbles in this chart number 2 here
Again show how private institutions were lured in the plug into the by the double-digit increase in house prices early as August
1919 in New England
Martine to think it's critical to show figures comparing mortgage losses by government versus those by the private sector
I'm not sure. That's true
but anyway
Here's Martin has not already published these same figures in the Moose report by
Itemizing mortgage losses that mark myths that should help to gain perspective on the long reach of government
Mark, estimated losses a 275 billion are based solely on those directly incurred by FHA Fannie and Freddie
this table as
itemized losses
directly in curbed by government or losses for which government is directly responsible notice that we end up with a full tally of
516 billion our first item of 41 billion comes right from
Fannie and Fannie's financial statements is the amount that private insurance companies paid them on losing mortgages
So while the forty 1 billion wasn't technically a loss of the enterprise's it was a loss imposed in the private sector by government
similarly fitting Fannie were able to get private sector issues to buy back many of their
Losing mortgages with threats the results of our second item
A managed to impose on the private sector 28 billion the 85 billion my atom represents losses that resulted from fannie and freddie
purchases of more than 700 billion dollars worth of subprime
Mortgage-backed securities and a hundred fifty being them high-risk securities called all day
The 40 billion Iowa item represents losses on huge private sector deals that only got implemented in response to government
Unfortunately the Community Reinvestment Act
the final display shows that losses properly attributed to government may be will higher than the losses attribute of the private sector we start with
This figures publishing marks moody study and make plausible adjustments
Begin with we reduced Moody's estimate of private losses by one hundred and thirty nine billion dollars
Based on the National Bureau crook Bureau of Economic Research working paper published last April which reports very different figures from Moody's
University of Chicago economist Paul
Harold pull off their paper writes in an email that he contacted mark twice
Asking for his sources and mark wouldn't provide them finally
We reduced Moody's number by 220 billion reflect all the losses mark attributed private said before which governments actually responsible
The result is government accounts for more than half and losses
I would also say
Absolute certainty from personal experience that a substantial percentage of private losses were driven by significant regulatory
Pressure on private institutions there wasn't a light hand
God was the hand of government pounding on your head trying to make you make subprime mortgages and we have the consequences of that
Thank you five minutes from our
Contact here, I'll give you my card. I
Get contacted by lots of people I maybe I don't know I
Send him my way. I'll be happy to set him straight. So John my read of your
Argument is
Twofold one is that the Federal Reserve was?
Overly stimulatory with monetary policy and the lead-up to the bubble and that exacerbated
Housing demand and therefore house price growth and ultimately
Helped create the bubble
In second that Fannie and Freddie because of their very aggressive
affordable lending lending to underserved groups
Helped to stimulate a more broader
erosion in underwriting standards across the system
And I'd say on on both I think there bit players in the story
with regard to the Federal Reserve
They
Did straight-up monetary policy they if you look at the interest you mean if you go back I can remember the sticks pretty well
That the federal funds rate hit a bottom. That's the key interest rate. The Fed control said the bottom of 1% in
the wake of the
Bursting of the stock market bubble in 2004 and then rose to five and a quarter percent at the peak
Just prior to the crash
If you kind of look back at that period and you look at the things that the Fed looks at and trying to set monetary
policy the so-called feds react function straight-up monetary policy
unemployment inflation
financial market conditions
You know broader global economic conditions. The the funds rate was very very close to you know, what those
Traditional approaches to monetary policy would be yeah, could you argue they could have done a better job in hindsight, obviously
You know that everyone screwed up but it's hard to put place the you know, the blame significant blame on them
they were just they followed the script and historically the script has worked pretty well since
1913 when the Federal Reserve was put on the planet
Clearly our financial system and economy have performed much better than than prior to that period with regard to Fannie and Freddie
I don't get that one at all
And I know there are some proponents of the idea that you know, Fannie and Freddie's lending to underserved communities
Is the cause a major cause of what happened?
I don't think there's any evidence of that
In fact, the academic literature is very clear. There's been a dozen different studies done on this issue controlled experiments
St. Louis, I would I would direct you to a couple of very good studies that done by the st
Louis Fed and the Fed Board of Governors
and
They come to the conclusion that the affordable housing goals had nothing to do with what happened
And you know, I I am
in faith, I think Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac because of
Their mission should be geared towards providing
affordable credit to
Lower in middle-income households. That's what they were put on the planet to do and and that's
their mission
I don't think the affordable housing goals are a particularly good way of getting them to achieve their mission
But it's not because they were the cause of the crisis or they lead to poorer underwriting
It's because they're totally ineffective. There's very little evidence. In fact, no evidence that those goals
There's affordable housing goals have had anything to do with
Fannie and Freddie's underwriting so, you know
with your arguments
You know, I wouldn't completely dismiss them
But if I had a list of ten different things ten different causes of the crisis, by the way
There are so many reasons for this crisis. That one could write a book and I did I did
Yeah, it's worth the dollar ninety-nine on eBay, but I would suggest you go read it because it kind of lays out
You know who's to blame? The Fed is a chapter in the book, but it is definitely a bit player in all of this
Thank you both for spirited exchange
We now move to the QA part of the evening
And would you guys will you be willing to do a little grunt work and move your chairs?
and I think that our sound guy wants to move the mics to make sure that our klutzy guys do not
wreck the mics and
we're going to do that and
We are going to start
With I guess moderators prerogative to to sort of pick up on a strand for each of you
First John Allison, do you acknowledge? What's your reaction to?
Mark's point that there was a failure of regulation
and in
India that there was a major sin of omission on the part of government with visa V the behavior of the private sector
Well, it was a fait
It was a failure of regulation
But it was the inverse of what Marx says there was huge pressure
on financial institutions to make low-income housing lives and it's important to understand the
Context because it really started with Bill Clinton and it wasn't about low income
It was about minority lending specifically the african-american community
So it was a huge pressure on financial institutions and you really couldn't
argue just about low income lending because it Mike like BB&T we were in low-income areas, but you had to prove that you were being
Super careful and and a lot of banks made a lot of regular loans that didn't classify this as subprime loans
too low
not low income bars with bars with lousy credit histories
You have to understand the lending business to understand that income that to debt service is one factor
but a bigger factor is just what people gonna pay you and and that
Encouraged this bubble and also became almost a moral campaign on the regulator's part. So
It was it was yes
It was a lot of regulatory pressure, but it was in the wrong direction from a credit quality
And by the way, a lot of regulators knew that you could hear them. They would tell you that
I'm not coming on that and that's good question and comment on John's answer. What do you want to pass about up to you?
Not never pass, okay
Let me tell you a story so
It was late 2005. I was asked to go brief the
FOMC this is the Federal Open Market Committee the folks at the Federal Reserve
Greenspan was this is just towards the end of his tenure at the Fed and they asked me to come speak about
the
Developing issues with regard to the mortgage industry. This was late 2005. So, you know, we were still a long way from the crisis
And but it was you know, you could feel things getting very frothy
a lot of investors flippers house price growth that now has gotten into the double digits and
I had some insight into it because I was able to tap into the rating agencies data
With regard to because really it's hard to hard to believe this but back at the time we didn't even know
There wasn't even a clear definition of subprime mortgage. We just kind of throw that term around
But in 2005 there no one really knew what that meant
so
But we had data from the from the private-label securities. And so I could look at that and
Gain some insight into what was going on. So I go into the meeting
At the Fed in DC and I get my presentation. It might have been I don't know half hour 45 minutes and they listened and
At the end of that there was not a single question. Not one question
Not one and I and I was pretty dark I was saying this is a problem
This is a weed if it can we're gonna have a real problem. I
Was writing extensively about it at the time and I wrote a piece called. Where are the regulator's
And I heard I had one question when I left that meeting
You know Greenspan was right there and he's looking at me. Not a question. I left that meeting I go
Oh my gosh, I have this wrong. I must have this wrong
They are saying what about this? They don't think there's an issue
There's not a problem
now here's the thing Greenspan had a stated policy of
I'm not gonna worry about bubbles. This is not my problem
You know Greenspan had you know, he did monetary policy in the Fed is the key regulatory body in the system, right? So
He had a state of policy of saying I'm not going to I don't know if there's a bubble or not
I'll clean up the mess when it blows and that's the policy
He was pursuing there was not a regulator in sight and the chief regulator was sitting right there and saying it's not my problem
Okay, and the question for mark did I believe that that Robert Shiller?
Called called up the price what some call the price bubble of price boom, but he specifically stated
recently, in fact that and I believe that John Cornyn that that the price boom the biggest price boom started in early 97
And went through 2006 and that it was more than half done
More than halfway through as a bubble of boom by 2003 would you now now is that based on prices that that did indeed occur?
And that there was indeed a major boom bubble that that that occurred from 97 through 2003 to 2006
Do you know it's that in terms of John's argument?
no, I
Think a bubble a housing bubble any bubble in it anymore what we call the boom. Let's go to boom
No, let's call it a bubble. Well, yeah, okay. It's a bubble
It's a bubble Wynn and Michael are buying homes or any asset a stock
Commercial property whatever it is based simply on the fact that they think that property is going to be worth a lot more
Soon in the future and I can sell okay, so tonight. Can I change my question?
Call it a boob just answer. Can I just simply say he called it a boom? So let's call it a boom
He said there was a price boom from today 97 that went through
2006 do you now let's chill this point that there was a price boom
As he put it not a probably put he called it a boom. So was it a boom? That's
Okay, let me answer the question this way. Okay the between up and through
The increase in housing values was very consistent with underlying fundamentals that drive
housing demand and house price growth
The there was strong house price growth
But you know
If you go look at the data look at any house price index you want to look at Case Shiller his index
Look at the FHFA at the time of sale price Series price growth was 5 4 5 6 % per annum
This is through mid
2003 and
household income growth in that period on average was 4 5 6 %
Rent growth was 4 5 6 % construction costs were 4 5 6 %
These are the fundamentals that drive underlying housing values
now there was a period when it got juiced up after the equity market fell because people
pulled money out of the equity market this was you know, 2001 was the crash in the equity market and people said well,
What did I put my money and they started putting it into the into the housing market?
The real switch went on in between mid 2003 in
Early 2007 it was in that period that house price growth went from 4 or 5 6 % pick your index
I know this data because I model it
This is what I do for a living. I
Model it
It went up into the double digits per annum it increased between 2000 in 2003 in mid 2007
And that was a bubble. That was a bubble because house price growth was
Disconnected from the growth in the underlying fundamentals and that was speculation
and so it was that period when this metastasized and became a
Problem for the financial system and ultimately the economy
So no, I don't I don't that all agree with the idea that there was a bubble prior to sorry a boom. Boom
There was a but I'm not okay, whatever. It was a bubble post-2000 you insisted on the word bubble
So that's why I said Shiller used the word. Boom. He said it was the one number one
Boom that started in 97 and went to 2006 boom is different than the bubble
You can have a boom if it's supported by underlying good fundamentals, right?
Comment from John I think shell arm in a bubble and
Anybody that was in the lending business was observed observing the obvious fact this goes back to the early nineteen to late 1990s the price
relative to people's income there for debt service when you finance a house relative to income was headed up very rapidly and
Reach in the late 1990s
Equivalence to the early 1990s when we had a housing bus and the early nineteen eighties me house had a housing bus
and and the price
To rinse was going nuts
Or in there were 99
We thought we were gonna have a housing correction in the early 2000 when the stock markets for correcting
this is when Greenspan stepped on the gas that was in this slide and started pumping out money like
Crazy, but book by loaner interest rate, but more than that right price
Pisces should have been falling when you have a huge increase in productivity
Because the entry of the Chinese and the Indians in the world market
Prices would normally fall if you think about if productivity is rising very rapidly
If you had a stable money supply prices would be falling if you don't let prices fall
it's worse than normal inflation because people don't realize
inflation is happening and they become overly optimistic and that is that Spurs a massive increase in consumption and
Housing is consumption not investment. So we had a huge miss allocation of capital away from capital investment
We weren't put anything in capital
He was running
you know the savings but is of his faith because US savings rates that were falling and
And and and and we were over investing in consumption and housing and it would have corrected in the early
1990s we had a little worth correction then and then we wouldn't have had to run up
I agree with Mark at the end of the bubble
A lot of people who jumped on just like they do in the stock market
but the momentum was already there that that's what carries that kind of stuff the
Bubble had already started and it got blown up by a bunch of fools. That should have gone broke
But but they were secondary players. I'm
Good. Thanks. And
Now also a moderator obligation to ask you before the audience ask questions
Do you want to ask your other a question now, or do you want to wait 40s?
But you always have the product of you guys other questions you want to wave on that or do ask each other a question
Ok, no
Questions for the audience, please phrase your question as a question as best you can
First question don't identify yourself as a person your credentials do identify just as so forum person a very well
Was a pretty weird
My name is Paul Muller. I teach economics downtown. I have students here. I saw him both of your books
We don't we don't care. All right, here's my question for mark mark. So it seems that
Underwriting standards are really important in this story and the declining underwriting standards. So my question is with countrywide and
indymac and these other sorts of unregulated
lenders and sort of the subprime area
Who was buying their loans in in 1999?
2000 2001 2002 before the private market and the investment banks jumped on that
So who woods buying them and could you comment on?
Alt a loans and sort of the difference between traditional
Prime loans and alt a loans which are not to poor people and yet are not the traditional
Prime loans with 20% down and other sorts of things
Thank you
Well, I think back in the late 90s early
2004 things really got going these companies were a shadow of the market. They were very small
I mean countrywide was the biggest and it was still, you know, pretty small player at the time
It really didn't these companies really didn't become
Significant players in the mortgage market until that period you know when you saw the private level securities market really take off
You know into that between 2003 and early 2007
So, you know, I don't I don't think they it was they were inconsequential in the grand scheme korean scheme of things
So, what was your second question?
When I say subprime generally in the context of this kind of a group I'm also considering all day
Option arms
Nega em arms
I'm really thrown in the hole any mortgage loan that you basically can't make today right because one of the
regulatory changes in dodd-frank
Was the so-called qualified Mortgage rule, but this is this is disbeliever this or not
This this rule is if you're a mortgage lender, you can't make a loan to a borrower who can't afford to pay it
That's the rule right?
that rule was not in place before dodd-frank and
These are the loans that are no longer in existence because borrowers can't afford to pay them, right?
So I include all of that in when I say when I study subprime, you know for this kind of an audience
Not for you know, he can't professor but you know for this kind of audience
Although maybe you're only compras. I
Not me
Thanks mark, John do you want to comment? No, okay next question
Hi do either of you view what is going on currently with student student loans to be anything similar to what happened?
with the the housing bubble
So if and if you do think it is a similar boom or bubble
Is there anything we can take from what happened back in 2008 that we can use to?
Avert a similar catastrophe if that bubble if it is a bubble does burst. Let me give it to John fresh because you
Winters in question, I think there is a key similarity and that is that
If you
Increase the amount of leverage to purchase something. I mean you allow people to borrow money in
Lenders extend credit to buy something and it's against a something that has a relatively fixed supply. It's hard to increase the supply
What happens is the price goes up? Right? You're just increasing demand and that's to some degree
What happened in the mortgage market right you through all this?
Borrowing on to the housing market and you had the supply was increasing but not enough and so that helped to drive up prices
That's the same principle in the loan student loan market
We are subsidizing the and we're giving subsidy to increase the demand for
Educational services and that's a very fixed supply. Right? So all you're doing is jacking up tuition
So at the end of the day, you're not really helping anybody
The poor kids are just loaded up with debt and you're on the you know, a treadmill
so the implication for me, I mean my takeaway from that and I'm talking as an economist without the strictures of
policy and having to make
Legislation that works just as an economist
I
would say I would take that subsidy that we're putting into
Student loan debt instead of making the interest rate low and making it more available
I take that subsidy that money that taxpayer money and I use that to increase the supply of educational services right community colleges
technical schools
ELearning
Increase the supply so if you increase the supply you bring down the cost
These kids don't have that debt and they have access to better educational services
That's easy to say and you know, it's it's very difficult to get there from here
But if I were king for the day, that's the path I would go down
I agree with Mark's analysis of what?
Student debt has done. It's just driven at the price universities
I think it is like the housing bond bubble in this sense and it is causing a massive
misallocation of resources
Because what's happening, and I'm very involved in the educational process
A lot of people are going to universities spending a lot of money not graduating or graduating with degrees where?
Their productivity hadn't been increased. So you've got a Mis
Allocation of the most valuable resource of all for human mind there's a lot of students at universities today
That ought to be in some kind of I don't
Want us call technical training demeaning
They ought to be learning how to do other things and what liberal arts
Universities tend to teach them to do and I think so. There's a double whammy it's the economics Marc talked about but it's also
You've seen something like 25 percent of the kids that graduate with college degrees are getting jobs
They don't need college degrees for I'd say
That make one another quick point. So one big difference is that there's 1.3 trillion in student loan debt outstanding
1.15 trillion is government backed right so
It's a taxpayer problem in the mortgage market
Just go back to my slide the vast vast majority of the debt was private market debt
and when that blew up that became a financial system problem, and that's why that that period in
2008-2009 was the financial crisis it took out the financial system. The student loan problem won't take out the financial system
it's our problem as taxpayers we
Did have a debate at the so forum about college a few months ago. I refer you to that on a website
The video and the audio are both available
Next question mark this one's for you. So private-label securities at the epicenter of the crisis
Investors bought them investors are bad market failure. Boom. You're done
Who bought them people who bought them for the rating, but they're just bad investors
They read consumer reports bought the wrong car. It was a lemon
Why did they buy them if they had a triple-a on them?
Is it because the bank capital rules said they could be undercapitalized and whole point six percent of capital to hold them
So if a nationally recognized statistical rating organization went to a bank
that's regulated by the government that said you could hold point six percent of capital if you bought a triple-a security and
Then clever people on Wall Street
Maybe not dissimilar from me went out and figured out a way to have some pride borrowers
Speculate on houses that were going up ten percent a year
To have Moody's and S&P issue triple-a securities to banks a couple point six percent of capital
How is that not a government induced distortion of markets? How do you not support the resolution?
You would yeah
No
You are not in charge of the ratings mark I say that on your behalf. So but go ahead. No. No, it's I'm sympathetic
What you're saying, it goes to the point. I made earlier about lack of regulation that
The system was undercapitalized and it was undercapitalized
Across the system. You mentioned one aspect of it Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac hold held 40 basis points of capital
You know back prior to the crisis. So if there was a government failure, it was a government
failure of regulation
So I'm I'm I don't disagree with that
I I think that did contribute now that wasn't the cause of the crisis
That was an exacerbation force that made the crisis as severe as it was Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
didn't cause the crisis but when the
losses started to mount because of what happened in the private markets and house prices started to decline as a result that wiped out their
Very thin capital they failed and it exacerbated the financial the finished price. It wasn't the cause. It was a it was a
a
Factor that contributed to the severity of the downturn if I could start a new century members, please. I'm sorry. We only a question
We can talk offline I'm very happy to yeah, of course talk offline and you are sticking around for the booze
Standard Poor's Moody's and Fitch had a government created
Oligopoly where basically they could they were the only rating agencies that you could use
For evaluating bonds and pension funds so they owned the bond rating business. They miss rated lots of instruments
dramatically
And that was government regulation that gave him the oligopoly by the way
I won right old you my company BB&T went through the financial crisis without a single court
He lost one reasons we wouldn't use to enforce Moody's and Fitch Ratings
because I've been to the
Economic correct early eighties. I've been to the economic surely 90s
I looked at these things and said any fool knows these are high risk instruments. They've reacted. I'm triple triple-a. I mean
Remember this too though terms of regulators
There was a regulation
you had to keep half as much capital and a
Subprime mortgage as you did to a loan to Exxon and you want to create an incentive for people to do subprime mortgages
Encourage banks to put half the capital and subprime mortgage and if you don't do that
By the way, that puts a lot of pressure on you because you can't perform this high in the short term
You know, the other guy's going broke, but you gotta stay in business
Or terms they put a lot of pressure on healthy institutions to do stupid stuff and some of them did some of them dude
Next question well to continue on the theme
Is Mark Zandi pointed out one of the contributing factors was the undue reliance on these?
ratings
In retrospect, they turned out to be worth not much more than a peewee soccer trophy has anything been done by the rating agencies to?
Improve their rate or make them actually worth something anymore
And
I'm sympathetic of the criticisms of the rating agencies. They mean like many of
Players in this system they screwed up. I mean, there's no doubt about that
Yes, there has been some changes
Remember in my opening remarks
I talked about the rating agency stated policy of not underwriting the underlying mortgages that had went into the securities
That has changed. So now they're
They use randomized
Sampling to go and take a look at the mortgages and they underwrite they can't underwrite every mortgage because there's millions of mortgages
but that that statistically is, you know an adequate way of
Approaching it
the
The kind of internal controls, you know another problem the rating agencies had back in
Pre-crisis was a problem with something called ratings shopping
that would be the investment banks would go to each of the
To the rating agencies and play one off the other and say if you give me basically was, you know, obviously not this blatant
But this was kind of the way things were being done
They would say, you know
If I get a better rating you'll get this the deal
and of course the fate that now is
There's no given all the changes in regular regulation and regulatory oversight
Rating shopping is a very very very unlikely thing to happen going for it possible. But we now we have very strong regulatory
controls and oversight
Over that process to make that much less likely. Oh
I'm sorry. I don't know. Can I just say this is a good point. This is a really good point so you're right
you know the inheritor feels like there's an inherent conflict right when you say
The investors pay the for the rating. So if someone's paying for the rating then the
agency is going to give a rating that the
investors want and I you know, I think that's
clearly a
problem an issue
but the thing is no one's come up with a better mousetrap because you know
it means you don't I mean when I say I should have said the rating agency is paid by the issuer not by the
Investor, right? It's the issue or that pays for it. Not the investor
There's a you know ideas that maybe the investor should pay for it. That's a pretty bad idea
Would you really want you know a hedge fund to be paying for the ratings?
Probably not
There's been ideas floated around of random
I randomly selecting rating agencies to do it so that you can't have this problem
There's all kinds of issues with that in terms of quality of the ratings and the analysis this time
So at the end of the day the system has now fallen back on
Let's keep the same approach the same model, but let's improve the regulatory
controls an
oversight
Better and more stringent regulation that wasn't there
You know pre-crisis is that mean that we're not gonna have a problem in the future, you know
I don't know but it's less likely we're going to problem in the future and we should fundamentally ask, you know
We the rating agencies are
an easy whipping-boy
But they're there for a reason and I won't go that's a whole other discussion
Maybe another debate but it's actually quite interesting to ask yourself. Why do we have rating agencies?
Because they play a very important role in the system
coming by John I
Think Morris why they've taken a lot of steps, but I would say this now. I'm retired from BB&T
But the day I retired we were still underwriting the bonds ourselves
We didn't trust the rating agencies and our experiences. Sometimes their ratings were pretty good and sometimes they
so I think anybody that's really a sophisticated buyer you can you can write you can write these things yourself within a
Within a range just by reading the instruments in there. So did I say that? I'm not in the reading agency?
Next question some of this has already been
Answered as I've been standing in the line, but I wanted to ask John
Can you give us some specific examples of the pressure that was put on BB&T?
to make loans and
or to
to
Join into the bubble as it was as it was going up and and the second part. What did you do to resist it?
How were you able to resist it at particularly being in the middle of a a?
low income and heavily minority community like you were
Yeah, well the pressure came from two sides
It came from the banking regulators themselves the FDIC and the Federal Reserve who?
Were very regulatory active the idea that that we were
Deregulation is absurd read the record
Regulations went off the chart. A lot of it was about compliance and not about
Lending but on the lending side there was huge pressure to get you to make affordable housing low income minority
Loans about what were the years John to just tell the years go in you account. What years was this?
It started back with Bill Clinton in the in the mid 1990s
Clinton was elected by a strong african-american community and he wanted to pay him back
He believed there was discrimination in the banking business
I don't believe there ever was we certainly weren't discriminating, but they put intense pressure on this starting in the late
1990s and then Freddie and Fannie
When they particularly when they had their accounting problems, they had to keep their government guarantees as they were left
They had there were leverage at one point a thousand to one
I mean they were broke before they were broke, but they got these survived with government guarantees. Then they cost called us
We were originating for Freddie and Fannie which we would have done cept
They have a government guarantee and they have a lower cost of capital which made it impossible for us to port for mortgages
They had driven down the standards radically to meet this affordable housing go which they bragged about
By the way, I mean they were proud of it
But they were doing and they were told us they were gonna cut us off from our prime business unless we did more
subprime business, so we danced around that there was also
Investor pressure to have the high performance you could get in the short term from doing this terrible stuff out of our big
We've actually run out of time for the questions
Mark, do you want to make a comment about what John just said about his own Lord. What do you want?
Okay
All right. Thanks. Thanks. Unfortunately, no more time for questions plenty of time to talk to the debaters after the debate
We're now going to go to the summary portion of the evening. John Allison. You're up with your summary
My summaries pretty basic it is
True that a number of private financial institutions played an important role and created the financial crisis
However, the primary culprits were the Federal Reserve and government housing policies specifically Freddie Mac and Fannie Mae
but also the FHA VA and
regulatory pressure that you could have half as much capital in a in a
Subprime mortgage as you could do a loan to Exxon along with the lots of other regulatory pressure
It is not true. The banking industry was deregulated. You can look at the record
there was a huge increase in regulations during this period of time and
And certainly there was plenty of greed on Wall Street if I've been in the banking business
47 years and there's always plenty of greed on Wall Street. It's all of its good some of its bad
There was no new amount of greed going on on Wall Street
it is hard unless you were down and down in the in the
Trenches when people get all these kind of numbers and pull of stuff out
You can't measure it the way it's being measured because a lot of private losses weren't technically in CRA loans
They weren't technically in private mortgage-backed securities
They were in loans that financial institutions were making it by the way
We keep saying the countrywide and Mack and Bank of America Citigroup
they were all regulated institution a huge percentage of them of the bad loans came out of companies that when fact were regulated and
Were encouraged to do subprime lending and we got the constant. It was a moral crusade. It's interesting people now
Barney Frank
And I the guys at the dodd-frank bill. They were the huge advocates of this crazy lending the time
I talked to both of them
we tried to show them that it's going to end badly and they just weren't interested in it because it was immoral to
Go for them we said well this ends badly for the borrowers but no no, this is the right thing to do
So it was a moral persuasion and the influence down in the trenches was dramatic
And yes
There were a lot of crazy people that did super stuff at the end of the cycle after the bubble had already blown up
Thank you
Thanks gene well, well thank you. It was a
Very enjoyable evening and great debate. And again, thanks for the opportunity to be here and really do appreciate it
And you know, I'm an economist
I look at the data I stick to the data and you know, the most telling statistic is the
Chart I showed
the madam mortgage debt that the private-label securities market accounted for
in the late 90s and early 2000s was less than 10 percent by
2006 early 2007 at the peak of the bubble
it was over 20% at the same time is
The share of mortgage debt that went to the private local securities market increased
The share of mortgage debt that went to Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
declined almost percentage point two percentage point
I mean
I think that's pretty clear who led the way here
And who is the principal culprit in causing the financial crisis, but let me just say a couple things about the future
And what we can take away from this
first thing I'd say is I
Feel better about the financial system post crisis because I do think the regulatory
oversight and regulatory framework today is
In a much better place than it was 10 years ago. The system is highly capitalized
very liquid
There's good risk management
Their stress testing their portfolios
They're adopting accounting standards that are more consistent with prudent risk management
I think the odds because of this improvement in the regulatory
environment
and
Oversight the odds of a financial crisis on the scale of what we experienced 10 years ago now are very very low
They're unlikely to happen. Certainly not in my lifetime
having said that though I am an economist and I can't end on a positive note, you know, there are things to worry about and
When you think about the financial system
In my simplistic way thinking about it
There is the regulated part of the system the system that Johns Bank BB&T is in
The banking system the depository institutions they account for about half of all the credit provided to the economy
The other half is the so-called shadow financial system and its shadow because it's not transparent
there's no light much less regulated and there are things going on in the shadow system that we need to watch and
Parts of the shadow market that are as ill defined as the subprime market was ten years ago. So
This is going to be a never-ending battle and we're going to go back and forth about government and private markets
But that battle is not over
It's gonna miss something we're gonna have to grapple with going forward
And if you really want to know what I'm worried about you'll have to ask me back for another debate. Thank you
Thank you for a very spirited debate we now go into the final voting
Portion of the evening again, please
Go back into your apps
The financial crisis of 2008 was caused mainly by government induced distortion of markets rather than caused
mainly by
Intrinsic market failure, please vote
Yes, no or undecided on the resolution. Okay
60.6%
Voted for the resolution on the pre those sixty percent that rose to seventy point eight percent
Picked up ten point one percent which points that's the number to beat
Then no went from fifteen point seven to seventeen to a nearly eighteen picked up two and a quarter
Both gained votes, but the yes vote spoke more but gained more John you got the tootsie roll
You